>> ♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WE WENT TO LAS VEGAS
LAST WEEK TO INTERVIEW THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UFC.
DANA WHITE.
WE ARE NOT SURE WHAT TO EXPECT.
WE WERE HIGHLY IMPRESSIONED.
-- IMPRESSED.
HIS EXPERIENCES ARE SIMILAR TO
BUSINESS OWNERS IN THIS COUNTRY.
THE DIFFERENCE IS HE FOUND A WAY
TO KEEP GOING.
DURING THE COVID LOCKDOWN AS THE
GOVERNMENT TRIED TO SHUT HIM
DOWN, CBS REPORTED THAT DANA
WHITES AN EPIDEMIC ON HIS HANDS.
THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE THAT HE
CONTRIBUTED TO THE PANDEMIC.
IT WAS ALL A LIE.
SO, THE POINT OF THE STORY IS
THAT DANA WHITE KEPT UFC ALIVE
DURING THE LOCKDOWNS.
DID NOT LAYOFF A SINGE PERSON.
-- SINGLE PERSON.
I HAVE NEVER DONE AN INTERVIEW
WITH HUMAN BLOOD ON THE FLOOR
AND I LIKE IT.
THE FIRST THING I NOTICED IS HOW
SMALL THIS IS IN REAL LIFE.
THERE IS NO PLACE TO RUN.
>> THIS IS A SMALLER VERSION WE
USE HERE.
WHEN WE GO INTO ARENAS WE USE
A BIGGER ONE.
THIS WOULD LOOK LIKE A MATCH BOX
IN SOME ARENAS.
THE ONE IN PAY PER VIEW IS MUCH
BIGGER.
>> Tucker: WHAT DO THE FIGHTERS
THINK ABOUT THIS SMALLER SPACE?
>> WE TALKED ABOUT FIGHTS ARE
MORE EXCITINGING IN THE SMALLER
ONES BUT THAT'S NOT TRUE.
>> Tucker: THIS IS YOUR ARENA
WHERE FIGHTS TAKE PLACE IN
A WORLD YOU CONTROL?
>> 100%.
THERE WAS BUILT -- WE PUT THE
LAST SCREWS IN THIS PLACE RIGHT
BEFORE COVID HIT.
THEY SHUT NEVADA DOWN AND WE
COULD NOT EVEN DO IT IN OUR OWN
FACILITY THAT WE CONTROLLED.
WE COULD HAVE CREATED A BUBBLE
HERE, BUT THE GOVERNMENT WOULD
NOT LET US.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE IN THE SPORTS
BUSINESS.
YOU ARE IN CHARGE OF THE SPORT.
THAT DOESN'T EXIST ANYWHERE
ELSE.
YOU ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
SPORT AND YOU CAN'T HAVE IN
PERSON EVENTS.
WHERE DOES THAT LEAVE YOU WITH
COVID?
>> IT WAS TOUGH.
COVID WAS THE TOUGHEST THING I
EVER HAD TO NAVIGATE IN THE
HISTORY OF THIS COUNTRY.
IF YOU LOOK WHERE WE CAME FROM,
THAT'S SAYING SOMETHING.
MY ATTITUDE WAS:
THIS IS AMERICA.
WE DON'T QUIT.
WE DON'T GIVE UP.
WE DEFINITELY DON'T RUN AND HIDE
IN OUR HOUSE ITSELF.
I FIGURED THERE HAD TO BE A WAY.
>> Tucker: COVID HAPPENS.
COMPANIES START LAYING OFF BIG
PERCENTAGE OF THE WORK FORCE AND
DON'T KNOW HOW LONG THE
QUARANTINE WILL REMAIN IN
EFFECT.
THEY HAVE PAYROLLS TO MEET.
YOU DIDN'T PLAY PEOPLE OFF?
>> NO, A LOT MY PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
WITH ME FOR A LONG TIME.
10 TO 20 YEARS.
WE DO EVENTS EVERY WEEKEND.
THESE PEOPLE WORK HARD.
THEY HAVE BEEN DEDICATED TO THIS
COMPANY AND TO ME.
IF YOU LOOK AT COVID, IT'S THE
SCARIEST THING TO HAPPEN IN THE
HISTORY OF MY LIFE.
TO JUST DUMP MY EMPLOYEES THE
MINUTE SOMETHING BAD HAPPENS,
THAT'S NOT THE WAY I AM BUILT.
IT WASN'T GOING TO HAPPEN NO
MATTER WHAT.
I WOULD RATHER SEE THE WHOLE
COMPANY BURN AND GO DOWN IN
FLAMES BEFORE I WOULD HURT MY
EMPLOYEES.
>> Tucker: I PAID EVERY DAY.
-- PAID EVERYBODY?
>> PAID EVERYBODY.
>> Tucker: A LOT OF MONEY GOING
OUT AND NONE COMING IN.
WHAT DO YOU DO?
>> FIGURE OUT HOW TO KEEP THE
SLOW ALIVE AND KEEP IT GOING.
I AM CLOSE TO THE ROYAL FAMILY.
THEY WERE DOING TESTING OVER
THERE.
WELL, IF THEY WERE DOING TESTING
THERE, WE COULD DO IT HERE.
IT WAS A MATTER OF FIGURING OUT
A PLACE WHERE WE COULD GO TO
BUILD A TRUE BUBBLE AND MAKE
SURE THE PEOPLE WERE SAFE AND
PUT ON EVENTS.
>> Tucker: WENT TO ABDLIT-DABI?
>> MIKE TYSON CALLED ME AND SAID
YOU CAN COME TO OUR ISLAND.
THERE WAS NO INFRASTRUCTURE.
THAT WAS OUT.
-- THEY SUGGESTED ANOTHER
ISLAND.
IT WAS THE ONLY TRUE BUBBLE THAT
EXISTED IN SPORTS.
THEY BROUGHT PEOPLE IN.
THE WORKERS IN THE HOTEL AND THE
RESTAURANT, ALL OF THE PEOPLE ON
THIS ISLAND WERE TESTED BEFORE
WE EVEN GOT.
THERE THE PEOPLE WE BROUGHT OVER
WE TESTED.
FLEW OVER OUR OWN PRIVATE PLANE
THAT ONLY WE WERE ON.
GOT TO THE ISLAND.
TESTED AGAIN AND TESTED MULTIPLE
TIMES UP UNTIL THE EVENT
HAPPENED.
THE ONLY TRUE BUBBLE THAT
EXISTED.
>> Tucker: THAT ALLOWED YOU TO
KEEP YOUR SPORT ON THE AIR WHEN
EVERYTHING ELSE SHUT DOWN?
>> RIGHTS.
>> Tucker: WHY DIDN'T EVERYONE
ELSE DO THAT?
?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I TOOK A LOT OF HEAT.
TOOK A LOT OF BULLETS.
>> Tucker: ON WHAT GROUND?
>> WELL, THAT'S WHAT THE MEDIA
DOES.
THE MEDIA DOES NOTHING.
THEY NEVER BUILT ANYTHING.
NOBODY DEPENDS ON THEM FOR
A PAYCHECK.
THEY SIT BACK AND CRITICIZE.
I AM GOING TO KILL PEOPLE.
I CARE MORE ABOUT MONEY THAN
HUMAN LIFE.
AND THE "NEW YORK TIMES" WAS
BLASTING ME DAILY.
>> Tucker: BECAUSE YOU WERE
TRYING TO KEEP YOUR EMPLOYEES
PAID AND FED AND KEEP YOUR
BUSINESS GOING?
>> RIGHT.
YOU ARE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
SOLUTIONS TO PROBLEMS.
EVERYBODY FELT LIKE IT WAS
A NARRATIVE DURING COVID IF YOU
DIDN'T RUN AND HIDE, YOU WERE
RECKLESS.
YOU WERE A MONSTER.
YOU DIDN'T CARE ABOUT OTHER
PEOPLE.
THE LIST GOES ON AND ON.
>> Tucker: SO --
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING].
>> THEY WERE WORKING.
THEY HAD NOTHING TO WORRY ABOUT.
THEY WERE WRITING HORROR STORIES
EVERY DAY AND THEY WERE WORKING.
>> Tucker: WHEN YOU ARE
CRITICIZED BY THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" IT'S HARD TO KEEP IT OUT
OF YOU?
>> IT WASN'T.
I LIVE IN MY ONLY LITTLE WORLD.
IN OUR OWN LITTLE BUBBLE.
I KNEW IF I WENT AND FIGURED OUT
A WAY TO DO IT.
MY TEAM WOULD GO WITH ME.
I KNEW THE FIGHTERS WOULD FIGHT.
AS LONG AS EVERYBODY FELT THE
SAME WAY, AND WE WERE NOT 100%
ALIGNED.
SOME FIGHTERS WERE NERVOUS.
NOBODY WAS FORCED TO FIGHT.
THAT'S HOW THEY FEED THEIR
FAMILIES TOO.
I KEPT EVERYBODY WORKING.
>> Tucker: WAS THERE ANY COVID
DEATH AROUND YOU?
THE "NEW YORK TIMES" SAID YOU
KILLED PEOPLE.
>> THERE WERE NO COVID DEATHS.
PEOPLE CAUGHT COVID.
I SENT OUT WEEKLY VIDEOS TO MY
EMPLOYEES.
ENJOY THIS TIME WITH YOUR FAMILY
AND RELAX.
IF YOU GET COVID OR ANYBODY YOU
CARE ABOUT GETS COVID, MAKE ME
YOUR FIRST CALL.
WE WILL GET YOU TAKEN CARE OF.
IF YOU NEED TOILET PAPER, YOU
WILL GET YOU THAT.
IF YOU NEED FOOD OR NEED
ANYTHING CALL US AND WE WILL
TAKE CARE OF YOU.
THROUGH COVID ME AND MY TEAM
BECAME STRONGER THAN WE HAVE
EVER BEEN.
ONCE IT IT WAS TIME TO GET BACK
TO IT WORK -- THERE ARE
COMPANIES NOT BACK TO WORK YET.
MY WHOLE TEAM IS BACK TO WORK 4
WEEKS INTO THE PANDEMIC AND
WORKED STRAIGHT THROUGH.
>> Tucker: DID YOU LOSE ANYONE?
>> WE DIDN'T LOSE ANYONE.
>> Tucker: YOU WERE LOYAL TO
YOUR EMPLOYEES AND NEVER HAD
STAFF PROBLEMS?
>> MY EMPLOYEES WERE LOYAL TO ME
FOR THE LAST 20 YEARS.
WHEN THE [BLEEP] HIT THE FAN I
WAS LOYAL TO MY PEOPLE.
THEY WERE LOYAL BACK.
WE GOT THROUGH THIS THING.
WE THREW ONE HELL OF A CHRISTMAS
PARTY LAST YEAR AND BROUGHT KIDD
ROCK IN AND PLAYED FOR
EVERYBODY.
IT'S LIKE IT NEVER HAPPENED
HERE.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE SHOWING THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY HOW TO STARE
DOWN ADVERSITY AND THRIVE.
DID ANY POLITICIANS CALL YOU TO
SAY I AM IMPRESSED BY WHAT YOU
ARE DOING?
>> YOU KNOW, THE PRESIDENT AT
THE TIME DID.
HE WAS VERY INTO IT.
FLORIDA WAS MASSIVE FOR US.
I WOULD EQUATE FLORIDA TO
ABU-DABHI.
THE GOVERNOR AND THE MAYOR OF
JACKSONVILLE TOLD US COME IN.
WE WILL HOST YOU HERE.
YOU CAN DO YOUR EVENTS HERE.
HAVE FIGHTERS FROM ALL OVER THE
WORLD.
THE FIGHTERS FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES WE BROUGHT INTO
ABU-DABHI.
THE OTHERS WE BROUGHT INTO
FLORIDA.
WE RAN OUR BUSINESSLIKE NOTHING
WAS GOING ON ALTHOUGH WE DIDN'T
HAVE FANS.
HOUSTON SAID I NEED YOU HERE.
HOW QUICK CAN YOU GET HERE?
I WILL BE THERE AS SOON AS YOUR
MAYOR LETS ME.
WE FIGURED OUT A DATE.
IT WAS HOUSTON, TEXA